you know everyone is talking about kim's
new relationship with pete davidson if
you had the chance to spend time with
them how are they as a couple
um you sit right here
perfect timing
thanks a little stormy webster her
grandma kris jenner was able to dodge
andy cohen's question about kim
kardashian and pete davidson's
relationship we're gonna show up for
each other because that's what we do on
friday chris appeared on cnn's new
year's eve live with andy cohen and
anderson cooper
and take a look at what happened near
the end of her segment when andy
attempted to get the tea on kim and pete
you know everyone is talking about kim's
new relationship with pete davidson if
you had the chance to spend time with
them how are they as a couple let's
rewind out of the corner of chris's
video you see kylie jenner and travis
scott's adorable three-year-old daughter
running in the room as if she was on cue
giving the 66 year old momager the
perfect opportunity to avoid giving an
answer
hey stormy oh
um you sit right here um yeah
nice distraction good timing stormy
perfect
i know right on to you
kris jenner thank you so much have a
great new year and just like that the
interview was over and chris has this
cute face to thank for getting out of
that one so really proud of her when it
comes to kim she rang in the new year
presumably in la with the rest of her
family
while pete davidson was in miami where
he teamed up with miley cyrus to co-host
the nbc special miley's new year's eve
party
they were so much fun kim and pete
sparked romance rumors shortly after she
hosted snl
and on december 18th the 41 year old
reality star and 28 year old comedian
were spotted having date night in pete's
hometown of staten island fans spotted
the two at the movie theater where they
were joined by scott disick
and the night didn't end there as they
were apparently in the mood for some
italian
a local restaurant shared these photos
to instagram where you can see pete kim
and scott posing in some selfies
it's been a lot of fun